buonasera allora mi fa molto piacere
essere qui
chiederete come mai parliamo di turismo
in intel come mai parliamo di un
attività che normalmente viene vista
come ampiamente residuale nelle nostre
vite
di solito parliamo di turismo quando non
lavoriamo e quindi viene vista come
qualcosa che potrebbe non essere
importante bene in italia il turismo è
sono circa mille miliardi sono un
milione di posti di lavoro 4,3 per cento
del pil
10 per cento se consideriamo anche
l'indotto e probabilmente è utile
riflettere come mai stanno succedendo
delle cose
in tutto il resto del mondo e in italia
stiamo rimanendo un po indietro e
francamente questo visto che siamo il
paese dove il turismo è nato a partire
dal grand tour del settecento è un po
seccante mi ha già presentato giacomo ma
se volete faccio tante cose andate su
google non perdere neanche un secondo
per dirvi cosa faccio trovare tutto
online
mi piace partire con le buone notizie
le buone notizie sono che il turismo è
tutto il mondo sta crescendo
nello scorso anno ci aspettavamo una
crescita del 4 per cento è invece chiusa
5 quindi più del previsto nel 2018 ci
saranno un miliardo e 8 di viaggiatori
attivi ed è il raddoppio rispetto a
sostanzialmente quanto sono i
viaggiatori attivi nel mondo adesso fine
buone notizie
l'italia è scivolata nell'ultimo
rapporto del country brand index dal
primo al settimo al dodicesimo al
diciottesimo posto il country brand
index è uno studio fatto da una società
indipendente che misura la percezione
del brand italia
ovvio non misura solo il turismo misura
ad esempio la qualità della vita misura
ad esempio la sicurezza misura tante
tanti aspetti ma è su molti siamo in
testa
siamo in testa sul turismo e cultura
quello che mi ha sorpreso è che siamo
assolutamente fuori classifica
su una cosa nella quale io pensavo di
essere fortissimi ad esempio la qualità
della vita è da vedere andatevelo a
cercare online e un'altra buona notizia
è che il 40 per cento mondiale vedete
questo il grafico in fondo quella torta
il 37 per cento di tutti i soldi spesi
nelle commerce nel mondo sono spesi nel
settore del turismo
questa è una buona notizia perché sono
tanti soldi e da una buona notizia
perché stiamo parlando di digitale
stiamo parlando di innovazione stiamo
parlando di una cosa nella quale siamo
bravi e che è controllabile e che non ha
bisogno di investimenti in fondo non c'è
da costruire un'autostrada c'è da fare
delle cose fatte bene che stanno
funzionando in tutto il resto del mondo
vi faccio vedere anche un dato che a me
ha scioccato tanto per farvi capire cosa
ci stiamo perdendo per strada
ho provato a mettere in relazione i
chilometri di costa di alcune
destinazioni con il numero di
pernottamenti in quelle stesse
destinazioni
adesso vedete la sicilia è paragonabile
più o meno a le baleari e alle canarie
come chilometri di costa
la puglia ne ha circa la metà queste
sono i pernottamenti
10 milioni la sicilia più o meno uguale
la puglia che quindi sta facendo un
ottimo lavoro
58 milioni le baleari 75 le canarie dove
stiamo sbagliando è solo un problema
infrastrutturale c'è anche quello
ovviamente ci sono più voli portano più
turisti
ma c'è un'altra cosa della quale mi
piacerebbe parlare oggi il mondo del
turismo sta profondamente cambiando il
modo con cui le persone con cui voi
scegliete dove andare in vacanza è
differente da quello di dieci anni fa ed
è profondamente differente da quello con
il quale lo sceglievano i vostri
genitori
intanto vorrei demistificare tre cose
che avranno rotto le scatole anche a voi
come me quando si parla di turismo ci
sono in italia tre grandi miti le slide
che seguono sono scritte in italiano per
quello che si sentono solo italiano uno
mito numero uno il turismo e il nostro
petrolio
quante volte l'avete sentito dire
saranno circa vent'anni forse anche di
più che si sente questa parallelo
orribile
il petrolio è una cosa brutta sporca non
eco sostenibile il petrolio è una cosa
che sta causando guerre il turismo non è
il nostro petrolio
il turismo è l'opposto del petrolio il
turismo eco sostenibile per definizione
è un patto di pace tra i paesi naturale
non si può viaggiare dove c'è guerra
guardate dove viaggiano le persone e il
turismo è l'unica industria che ha
ricadute dirette sul territorio
naturalmente il turismo non è il nostro
petrolio smettiamo di dirlo perché è una
cosa francamente imbarazzante
secondo mito non vogliamo trasformarci
in una disneyland questa è una cosa che
mi mette mi manda assolutamente in
bestia come se disvelante fosse una cosa
brutta il 20 per cento dei turisti di
parigi fanno a disneyland sono la tutti
i parchi di divertimento disney fanno
più visite di roma e non vi dico perché
non me lo ricordo in noi soldi che
genera come fatturato e ovviamente
l'indotto che porta ci sono decine di
studi sul terreno
forio light is della non è una cosa
brutta assolutamente
magari trasformassimo qualcosa del
nostro territorio in una disneyland
terzo mito se io adesso mi dicesse bene
finiamo questa magnifica giornata e
andiamo tutti a cena in un bellissimo
ristorante turistico quanti di voi
vengono con me pochi la parola turismo
ha un problema semanticamente a un
problema la parola turismo non è una
cosa bella
un ristorante turistico una località
turistica è un ristorante turistico è
scarsa qualità se mai vi fregano quindi
da quando è successo provate a
riflettere quel turisti è una parola che
emerge in una ricerca semantica fatta
sulle migliaia e migliaia di
conversazioni in lingua inglese
sull'italia
ed emerge sempre questa parola turisti
ci sono dei posti che vengono chiamati
turisti cioè turistici in senso
dispregiativo
questo è il vero problema il vero
problema è che noi abbiamo un tesoro che
è la bellezza diffusa dell'italia e
cerchiamo di renderlo turisti che non è
una disneyland è un altra cosa è la cosa
più difficile è adesso vediamo è provare
a cambiare da turisti a autentico che
cosa sta cambiando nei viaggiatori
intanto i viaggiatori non vogliono più
essere chiamati viaggiatori i turisti
non vogliono essere più chiamati di
turisti i viaggiatori vogliono vivere
una destinazione perché pensate il
successo di airbnb è tutto qua io voglio
visitare fossi stranieri voglio venire
in italia e vivere come gli italiani per
questo vado in una casa e scelgo sempre
meno l'hotel oggi andate a cercarlo
online se eravate quando lo avete visto
è uscita una ricerca sul sole 24 ore che
dice che confrontando i dati delle
strutture ricettive in italia con quelle
ufficiali dell'istat quindi le strutture
ricettive dell'istat con quelle che si
trovano ad esempio su tripadvisor quelle
su tripadvisor sono il doppio e quindi
perché lì ci sono contate quelle che
fanno reputazione quindi anche le case
ad esempio su airbnb
c'è un video bellissimo del lanciato
dall'istituto del turismo dell'isola di
okinawa che finisce con queste parole
con blend vi do with hoc in acqua cioè
venite affondarvi with okinawa loro sono
stati il primo paese al mondo la prima
destinazione che ha cambiato il loro
sito non è più visit in aula ma b
okinawa è un cambio semantico radicale
infatti se io vivo una destinazione non
voglio cose da vedere come quando visito
voglio esperienze da vivere
se io vivo una destinazione
non ho bisogno di una guida io ho
bisogno semplicemente che qualcuno mi
dia una connessione è la prima fonte di
lamentazione in un hotel o in una
destinazione è che non ci sia il wifi
free
provate a pensarci di cosa avete provate
a chiederlo ai vostri figli per chi ha
figli o ai vostri nipoti
la prima cosa che si fa in un paese
straniero è si acquista una sim o si
cercano wifi per raccontare quello che
sta succedendo
ormai la tecnologia è così diffusa che
si usa in qualsiasi momento della del
del viaggio prima durante dopo che
diventa quasi difficile accorgersene
questa foto è una foto di proclamazione
di papa ratzinger 2005 stessa foto
stessa angolazione 2013 papà francesco
pensate alla quantità di dati che
vengono prodotti da tutti questi
dispositivi che usiamo quotidianamente e
c'è un fenomeno interessante the rise of
salem pivot cioè persone che sono
disposte a spendere di più e sono più
contenti di quello che stanno provando
se riescono a concludere l'esperienza
online non giudicate non è una questione
di alienazione è una questione di
semplicità d'uso è una questione di non
doversi sbattere per fare delle cose che
si fanno più semplicemente attraverso
dei dispositivi digitali
a proposito di user experience e
tralascio cosa succederà quando arriverà
anche in italia il sistema dei pagamenti
e provate a pensare cosa ha comportato
il digitale in termini di sharing
economy airbnb o tutto il fenomeno dei
low cost è direttamente frutto del
digitale e provate a pensare anche come
cambiato la linea di attribuzione della
fiducia si sceglie sostanzialmente
attraverso quello che altri hanno
porzioni di esperienze di altre persone
ed è naturale che sia così
ultima cosa nel minuto e mezzo che mi
rimane che è quella che fa ancora più è
la cosa più seccante è che non siamo più
in grado di raccontare la nostra
bellezza
le uniche cose che funzionano nel
raccontare la bellezza non è ormai fare
pubblicità comunicazione tradizionale
non funziona più nessuno
provate a pensarci voi qual è l'ultima
pubblicità che avete visto che vi ha
provocato un comportamento d'acquisto
probabilmente qualcosa c'è sarà legato
al cibo ma non certamente legata al
mondo dei viaggi
vi faccio vedere minacciate il villa
audio del video due video questo solo un
secco solo qualche secondo questo è il
video fatto dalla promozione turistica
australiana perfetto così
video bellissimo tecnicamente
impeccabile non racconta nulla e se lo
guardate cercatelo su youtube c'è più
belle persone bei posti non vi fa venire
voglia di andare in australia e non
racconta nessuna storia d'amore
guardate questo
desidero star bng che just wright gen
chiuse chrome il centro di jesi vecchio
inside
insomma
ma
il bike sharing
ormai io mamma
if you're happy wine and spirit of
assisted doppio show no
due membri new york times
niente umane
and pop o membri the life extension e
penso che andrò ad pensione
già
dai
vorrebbe riunire
il neo in più dobbiamo smetterla di
raccontare quanto siamo belli e provare
a raccontare quanto siamo emozionanti e
l'unica cosa che le persone si
ricorderanno e vado alla fine
concludo con una frase di carlo petrini
che mi piace tantissimo anche perché un
segno di speranza in un convegno lo
scorso anno a genova carlo petrini ha
detto il turismo del futuro parte dai
cittadini residenti dalla loro qualità
della vita dalla capacità di essere
felici ed alla loro cura verso la terra
che abitano i turisti arriveranno di
conseguenza
grazie